Happy Thanksgiving I hope you're all
enjoying a wonderful day sitting maybe
in a nice comfy chair relaxing one of
the problems with Thanksgiving though
and we've all experienced it in recent
years is when your purple haired liberal
lesbian niece or nephew these days
starts spouting off about how terrible
America is and how the people who helped
to build this great nation were awful
evil genocidal Maniacs you know this is
going to get a lot worse now that the
orange man is back and is declaring he's
running for president they're going to
turn the vitriol up to 11. so I want to
arm you with some facts for this
Thanksgiving season because the story
that we are told by the liberal
establishment about Thanksgiving is just
complete bunk the evil terrible
Englishman who came and stole the land
and were so terrible to the Indians and
blah blah blah it's nonsense the real
history is actually much much more
interesting and edifying than all of
that so without further ado enjoy the
true story of Thanksgiving the land was
ours before we were the lands those are
the words of Robert Frost but they could
have been uttered by the pilgrims who
were convinced of a Divine Providence
guiding their Voyage on the Mayflower to
found a New Canaan in the new world I'm
convinced of it too we will explain the
true story of the Mayflower the pilgrims
Thanksgiving and our national Destiny
the left today mocks claims of a Divine
hand in our founding in the founding of
our country I think the reason they can
so easily dismiss Providence is because
they're almost entirely ignorant of the
history this is why they'll also claim
that purely benevolent Indians
selflessly saved the Pilgrims from
starvation only to be betrayed by the
English ingrates and callously wiped out
that didn't really happen Thanksgiving
is the cause of much historical
myth-making I don't mean the Divine
Providence of the Pilgrim's passage that
part is undeniable I don't mean the
myths of the Patriotic variety that the
pilgrims and the natives sat down they
shared food and goods together they
forged bonds of friendship and peace all
of that happened too I mean the myths of
revisionism war came no doubt but the
circumstances under which war came after
55 years of relatively unbroken peace is
far more complicated than the
revisionists would claim the pilgrims
were not greedy conquistadores and the
Indians weren't helpless Innocents War
might have come sooner peace might have
persisted for longer but for the actions
and decisions of particular men reacting
to complex circumstances
I personally have a particular interest
in the Mayflower voyagers because
despite my swarthy Sicilian skin tone I
descend from four of them only one of
them was a pilgrim Dr Samuel Fuller
he was the only physician in the colony
although his medical training is
somewhat doubtful my credentials are a
little doubtful too three of them were
so-called strangers these were the
non-pilgram passengers on the Mayflower
they were not religious zealots some of
them were downright degenerate one great
great great grandpappy Knowles is
Stephen Hopkins who 11 years prior to
the mayflowers voyage had already
traveled to the new world and he had
Shipwrecked in Bermuda an incident on
which Shakespeare's The Tempest is based
another is Francis Eaton and the third
is John Billington who Plymouth Governor
William Bradford called a Nave with a
family that was quote one of the
profanest among them great grandpappy
Billington appears to have been the
biggest degenerate of the Plymouth gang
he was regularly punished for rabble
razzing and eventually he was executed
for murder his son John wandered off and
almost caused a war and his wife Eleanor
was sentenced to sit in the stocks and
be whipped for slander family memories
they come back to me enough about my
derelict ancestor back to the Providence
did God ordain the Mayflower passage and
the founding of America Governor
Bradford certainly thought so in his
account of Plymouth Plantation he wrote
of the group they knew they were
pilgrims that's why we call the voyagers
pilgrims they wrote of themselves quote
we verily believe and trust the Lord is
with us and that he will graciously
Prosper our endeavors according to the
Simplicity of our hearts therein it is
not with us as with other men whom small
things can discourage or small
discontentments cause to wish themselves
home again
that was a good thing because just about
every obstacle imaginable appeared to
prevent the mayflower's voyage
the pilgrims for those who don't know
they came from a separatist church that
thought the Church of England was so
corrupt it could not possibly be
reformed from within and must be opposed
from without one can only imagine what
they would think of my own potpourri of
one of their descendants in the 16th
century several separatists had been
jailed and killed and since the 1603
coronation of King James pressure to
conform began to mount so the pilgrims
left England for Leiden Holland after a
decade there the group feared their
children were becoming too Dutch a fate
worse than death and so they decided to
found a new colony in the new world
where they could worship God as they saw
fit unmolested by overbearing
governments and those decadent Dutch
those damn decadent Dutch but as they
prepared to depart Pilgrim William
Brewster published a tract critical of
King James and his Bishops now as a
Young Man Brewster had served as an
assistant to Queen Elizabeth's Secretary
of State a man named William Davison and
now the king ordered his arrest which
forced Brewster into hiding not good
time nevertheless they persisted the
pilgrims contracted Master Christopher
Jones and his sweet ship the Mayflower
along with another vessel called the
Speedwell the Mayflower was called a
sweet ship because it had sailed the
English Channel for over a decade
carrying French wine and the spilled
French wine tempered the stench of the
bilge on the ship
some might see the pervading presence of
the wine in this First Act of departure
the first miracle performed by Christ
and a symbol of Christ himself as an
early glimpse of God's plan for the
pilgrims regardless more trouble lay
ahead the second ship the Speedwell
sprang a leak after reaching Southampton
and another at Dartmouth having decided
that the ship was unable to sail all of
the passengers loaded up on the
Mayflower the only later was it learned
that the speedwell's master Captain
Reynolds had been conspiring against the
pilgrims it was no mistake
the Dutch you remember those damn
decadent Dutch they had sought to
prevent the English from settling
Manhattan and so they enlisted Reynolds
in their efforts to thwart the
transatlantic Voyage ironically this act
of sabotage may have saved the colony in
its early years by forcing all of the
passengers onto one ship the separatists
and the strangers had to learn to
cooperate with one another had the
Speedwell survived there likely would
have been very little contact between
the two groups one was drawn to one ship
one to the other
now the pilgrims saw evidence of God's
work in just about everything it's an
evil generation that looks for signs and
wonders but it's a stupid generation
that ignores signs and wonders almost
immediately a sailor began to mock the
Pilgrim's seasickness you can imagine it
see hardened sailor starts making fun of
these Christian zealots as Bradford
tells it quote a proud and profane young
man would always be condemning our poor
people in their sickness and cursing
them daily with Grievous execrations the
young man boasted of hoping quote to
help to cast half of them overboard
before they came to their Journey's End
Bradford goes on though but it pleased
God before they came half Seas over to
Smite this young man with a grievous
disease of which he died in a desperate
Manner and so was himself the first that
was thrown overboard not to put too fine
a point on the incident and what it
meant for the pilgrims project Bradford
wrote quote it was an astonishment to
all his fellows for they noted it to be
the just hand of God upon him the rest
of the sailors kept their mouths shut
smart guys after 65 days the Mayflower
made landfall not at their intended and
legally granted destination of New York
but hundreds of miles Northeast at Cape
Cod where the settlers had no legal
right to the land they had been granted
Land by the Hudson River but not where
they landed when the passengers learned
of this a group of mutineers led by not
one but two of my ancestors rose up to
make quote discontented and mutinous
speeches fortunately few on board
listened to them and the voyagers signed
the Mayflower Compact a quote Covenant
to combine ourselves together in a civil
body politic for our better ordering and
preservation and furtherance of the ends
of War said
the land was not much to look at
Bradford called it quote a hideous and
desolate Wilderness Stranger Than the
environment however was its lack of
people there just wasn't anybody around
it was unpeopled because between 1616
and 1619 Bubonic plague or some similar
disease was introduced by European
fishermen in modern Maine it killed an
estimated 90 percent of the inhabitants
of New England the disease prompted an
outbreak of War among various tribes
vying for power in the chaos people died
so quickly no one remained to bury the
dead which left the pilgrims to wonder
at the whitened bones lying in cleared
Fields the Indians already had some
familiarity with Europeans in 1614
Captain John Smith of Pocahontas Fame
that one the cartoon guy he led a voyage
around the region during which his
Commander Thomas Hunt captured and
enslaved a group of natives this led the
Indians to slaughter all but three or
four of a later group of French
Travelers who Shipwrecked on Cape Cod
the next year in 1615. the men who were
spared ended up being tortured and
enslaved but one one of them promised an
Indian in the Indian's own language
that God was angry with them for their
wickedness and would destroy them and
give their country to another people
this was a prophecy doubtless fulfilled
and another evidence of the almighty's
plan for the pilgrims by Provincetown
Harbor where the pilgrims first landed
they found a gigantic bushel of corn
they just found it sitting there this
huge they were starving they were
worried about their ability to feed
themselves and there was just a huge
sack of corn so much that two men could
not carry all of it and they debated
whether or not to take it but they
feared starvation so they decided to
grab the corn and compensate the bushels
owner later on because as you know it's
easier to ask forgiveness than
permission the pilgrims did however
refuse to loot what appeared to be
Indian burial places despite finding
bows and arrows there certainly they
would have been useful to the pilgrims
but they said quote it would be odious
unto them to ransack their sepulchers
within a short spell at least 30 Indians
descended on the pilgrims screaming war
cries and flinging arrows miraculously
not a single Mayflower passenger left
the encounter with a scratch
they realized their new neighbors were
not exactly well disposed toward them so
Bradford set out to look for a better
settlement option after a month he
discovered Plymouth bay where the
situation was even stranger there were
whole Fields perfectly cleared for
agriculture but there were no people to
cultivate them Bradford saw in this a
clear sign from the Lord a place that
they randomly found apparently randomly
found perfectly cleared and ready for
them to plant you'll return to the
Mayflower to share his Discovery he was
so thankful to God but Upon returning
tragedy struck
Bradford learned that Dorothy May his
wife of seven years and mother of his
three-year-old son had slipped over the
side of the Mayflower and drowned you
might be thinking Hmm it's difficult to
slip over the side of an anchored boat
and you would be right well historian
Cotton Mather called the death an
accident many believe it to have been a
suicide the temptation to despair was
strong Dorothy May hadn't seen her son
in four months a seven-year-old child on
the ship had just died and two more
children were ill to the point of death
on top of all of that and on top of the
typically cold New England weather a
little ice age had descended on the
region until Bradford's return five days
after his wife's death the Mayflower
passengers had little reason to expect
their lot would improve Bradford himself
then fell ill as the voyagers settled
into Plymouth he requested some beer
from the Mayflower to Aid in his
recovery the Sailor is fearful that
their booze Supply would run out before
they made it back to England
well the water at that time was
virtually undrinkable so they needed to
drink beer on the way they responded
that if Bradford were their own father
he should have none quote
remember what happened to the last
sailor who gave pilgrims lip you might
remember in a replay of that incident
they all started to get sick and die The
Coincidence even prompted one young
officer on the ship to a deathbed
conversion Master Jones too had a change
of heart and he gave the pilgrims their
beer smart guy during February and March
of that horrible winter two or three
colonists died per day two or three per
day by Spring a majority of the settlers
who had originally arrived at
Provincetown 52 out of 102 were dead
here's where things start to get really
really strange
as if they weren't strange enough
already here's where it gets to Occam's
razor on March 16th just two or three
months after settling in at Plymouth a
lone Indian walked boldly out of the
woods toward the pilgrims they grabbed
their muskets stood on guard none of
that deterred the Indian he saluted his
new neighbors and said two words welcome
Englishman
he was tall he had long hair no beard he
was naked as the day he was born
interestingly for the racial Politics
revisionists the pilgrims made no
mention in their records of his race of
the color of his skin the man's name was
Samoset he was a Sachem visiting from
Maine where he'd learned some English
from fishermen and he just happened to
be visiting in precisely the area at
precisely the time the English had
accidentally landed after they missed
New York but didn't notice sail up to
the next nicest Harbor in Massachusetts
Bay just right there right exactly where
they were apparently by accident if that
weren't coincidental enough in the
following days Samoset returned with
another Indian who spoke virtually
perfect English He chatted with the
pilgrims about his favorite areas of
Spain and his favorite neighborhoods in
London that man's name was Squanto years
earlier Squanto had been abducted by
Thomas Hunt sold into slavery in Spain
escaped or was possibly rescued by monks
made his way to England somehow hopped a
boat to Newfoundland and walked all the
way down to Plymouth where the Pocono
could Indian chief Massasoit enslaved
the Pocono and Indian chief right near
where the pilgrims landed right at the
Mark that they happened to land the
pilgrims after landing 300 miles off
their Mark stumbled on perhaps the only
person in the Western Hemisphere with a
command of the English language
this is the Occam's razor port Occam's
razor says among competing hypotheses
the one with the fewest assumptions
should be selected
so either endless unique and impossibly
improbable events just happen to occur
or God sent Squanto to help the pilgrims
I know which one I think Squanto
unsurprisingly became the liaison
between the Pilgrims and their new
neighbors the poconocuts William
Brewster ever the Diplomat orchestrated
a diplomatic reception of the Pokemon
with pillows and carpets and trumpets
and drums within only a few years
Squanto had gone from a slave to the
single most powerful person in the
region as only he could communicate
between the English and the Indians and
he used his new form found power to his
advantage
Squanto was a true friend of the Indians
he helped them plant corn he was
indispensable Governor Bradford loved
him like a family member he also played
the situation to get an upper hand on
Massasoit in the poconocuts
there's a bit of strange symbolism in
the name Squanto itself
Squanto was named after the indian
spirit of night and darkness and cold
wind
Spirit the pilgrims identified with the
Devil
there was another one another
indispensable Indian to the pilgrims a
man by the name of habamak was also
named after this Spirit Nathaniel
philbrick in his excellent story The
Mayflower in his excellent book he puts
it well a group of people so singularly
devoted to serving God that they sailed
Halfway Around the World to do it became
entirely dependent on two Indians named
Satan
the surrounding Indian tribes in turn
became jealous of the Pocono Indian
Alliance as it greatly strengthened
mazusoe's position in the region the
matapoisett chief corbaton tried to
break the alliance by capturing poor
little Squanto he even held a knife to
the poor man's neck but while the
pilgrims were generally peaceful it is
nevertheless and always remains a bad
idea to mess with fire and brimstone
zealots who know they have God on their
side Governor Bradford ordered
plymouth's military commander Miles
Standish to go after korbitant with guns
blazing Standish was already chomping at
the bit to do it and wouldn't you know
all of this had the effect of making all
the petty sachems much friendlier toward
the English funny how demonstrations of
strength work
this brings us to the first Thanksgiving
we wouldn't forget about Thanksgiving it
occurred around Michael Miss Michael
Miss which is in late September early
October contrary to popular revisionism
it actually did resemble not only our
20th century ideas of Thanksgiving but
even the dinners that we have today it
actually was fairly similar there was a
lot of corn squash beans barley peas
they did eat turkey they ate ducks and
geese they possibly also ate striped
bass and Bluefish and cod NASA soad and
his Indian Pals showed up with around
100 people more than twice the English
population of the colony but he knew his
manners and he didn't show up
empty-handed he brought five freshly
killed deer the entire meal was cooked
by the four adult women who survived
that awful first winter half of whom
laid the genetic line all the way down
to little old me this Festival however
was not religious in the way that we
would consider Thanksgiving they didn't
even call it Thanksgiving the real
Thanksgiving didn't happen until two
years later in 1623 when Governor
Bradford officially declared a day of
Thanksgiving
this was a civil Affair recognized by
the Civil Authority and it didn't
celebrate English Indian cooperation as
they may have celebrated two years
earlier rather the pilgrims were
thankful that year that they ditched
communism in favor of private property
which had in turn given them abundance
you see the pilgrims had tried what they
called the common course not common core
that's also bad but the common course
communal ownership of property land and
wealth turns out it made everybody lazy
dishonest and thieving shocking I know
on the brink of starvation in 1623
Bradford instituted private property in
his words quote this had very good
success for it made all hands very
industrious so as much more corn was
planted than otherwise would have been
by any means the governor or any other
could use and saved him a great deal of
trouble and gave far better content the
women now willingly went into the field
and took their little ones with them to
set corn which before would allege
weakness and inability whom to have
compelled would have been thought great
tyranny and depressed session it's
amazing when you give people a stake in
their own abundance and their own work
it turns out they work more and by the
way this was not just a conclusion about
a particular experience Bradford
explicitly condemned communism in all
its forums and all its lies and all its
empty promises as absurd and contrary to
God's will he explained quote the
experience that was had in this common
course and condition tried sundry years
and that amongst Godly and sober men may
well events the vanity of that conceit
of Plato's and other ancients applauded
by some of later times little did he
know of even later times that the taking
away of property and bringing in
community into a commonwealth would make
them happy and flourishing as if they
were wiser than God
within two years of landfall these
earliest Americans already realized that
communism is the worst anti-communism is
as American as apple pie and
Thanksgiving
While most local Indian tribes played
nice the narragansetts refused to abide
the Pocono English Alliance and they
threatened War by sending arrowheads
wrapped in snakeskin to the pilgrims and
Squanto oh they're not going to take
that so the pilgrims sent bullets and
gunpowder wrapped in snakeskin right
back another reminder it is not a good
idea to mess with religious zealots who
travel around the world to live in
freezing desolate Wilderness because God
is on their side do not mess with those
people ever now like any sane Society to
protect against threats from without the
pilgrims built a big beautiful wall
around their settlement hundreds if not
thousands of trees were filled the
pilgrims lugged the mass of Timber by
hand and it stood more than half a mile
in length and over eight feet tall the
Wall's construction was met by shrieking
protests and stupid pink hats I'm just
kidding that wouldn't happen in America
for almost 400 more years Indian
relations continued relatively well very
often with the pilgrims playing
peacemakers and intervening on behalf of
their Indian friends with other tribes
when Massasoit demanded squanto's head
after an attempted coup the pilgrims
begged for his life massasoa agreed
though likely he later poisoned him
anyway on his deathbed Squanto asked
Bradford to pray for him that he might
go to the englishman's god Bradford
called Squanto quote a special
instrument sent of God for their good
beyond their expectation it's impossible
to argue with that he clearly was the
pilgrims at Bradford's command later
saved massasoa's Life by rushing to his
deathbed cleaning his sores cooking him
food administering what little medicine
they had doing anything they could no
matter how degrading no matter how how
ethereal for Massasoit to thank them
massasoa told the English of the
Massachusetts
unprovoked plan to attack The Colony the
Massachusetts were going to strike
but this put Radford in a difficult
position the pilgrims didn't want to
attack the Massachusetts without
provocation but if they waited for the
Massachusetts to strike they were doomed
the Massachusetts wanted to take care of
some Englishmen on their property and
they knew they'd have to hit Plymouth
too so what happened
Bradford gave the order Sanders set the
trap in the English averted War by
carrying the head of Sachem utuamat back
to Plymouth
now it's funny to think of those Bush
era activists who screeked about how
awful and unprecedented preemptive war
was for America literally the first
major military assault waged by our
country was preemptive not only that it
worked war was averted and the Indians
who conspired against the pilgrims
apologized profusely they made amends
and Massasoit Consolidated his power
even further creating thanks to the
pilgrims For the First Time The
Wampanoag Nation
peace persisted for decades as the
Massachusetts Bay Colony and other
colonies were formed Harvard College was
founded Indians converted to
Christianity by the tribeful and as a
result Indians ranked among some of the
earliest alumni of Harvard I'm certain
they were far better educated than those
shrieking snowflakes today missionary
John Elliott translated the entire Bible
into a phonetic version of the
Massachusetts language since the
Massachusetts hadn't developed their own
written language both the Old and the
New Testament as happened 1600 years
prior in Europe the Advent of
Christianity threatened the political
power of sachems because Christ's
Conquest on of death on the cross
removed political leaders only claim to
Authority and this led to jealousy now
among other Indian tribes
peace endured virtually unbroken for 55
years it only broke when masses saw its
own son Philip wrongly blamed the
English for the death of his brother who
more likely died of appendicitis or some
other natural ailment
Philip vowed Revenge he began selling
off land to raise funds for war and he
thereby exacerbated the need for war
local Indians notably the Christian and
Harvard Alum John sassamon warned
Plymouth of Philip's plans for war many
local tribes rebuffed Philip's
belligerence and sided with the English
Philip even made an alliance with the
French against the English an offense
unforgivable not only to you and me and
all right-thinking people but also to
the Fierce and not infrequently
cannibalistic Mohawk Tribe who promptly
sided with the English
looking back it seems miraculous that
peace endured so long until tragically
the hot-headed child of the Pilgrim's
dear friend Massasoit acted on a bad
hunch and destroyed more than half a
century of mutual benefit and
cooperation setting the English
permanently on their course to possess
the Whole New World
reflecting on the abject Misery the
pilgrims endured at the mayflower's
landfall the miracle of their survival
and their great thanks to God for
protecting his people William Bradford
wrote quote
what could now sustain them but the
spirit of God and His grace
may not and ought not the children of
these fathers rightly say our fathers
were Englishmen which came over this
great ocean and were ready to perish in
this Wilderness but they Cried unto the
Lord and he heard their voice and looked
on their adversity
the quintessentially American poet
Robert Frost looked on the country's
Destiny with an additional three
centuries perspective he wrote
the land was ours before we were the
lands she was our land more than a
hundred years before we were her people
she was ours in Massachusetts in
Virginia but we were England's still
Colonials possessing what we still were
unpossessed by possessed by what we now
know more possessed
something we were withholding made us
weak until we found out that it was
ourselves we were withholding from our
land of living and forthwith found
salvation in surrender
such as we were we gave ourselves
outright the deed of gift was many Deeds
of War
to the land vaguely realizing Westward
but still unstoried artless unenhanced
such as she was such as she would become
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show Happy Thanksgiving
mmm